ins mekka einem sanften fuhr zu einem
neuen video leute es wird zeit für den
zweiten teil von dinge probieren die wir
nie leiden konnten mag sich heute mit am
start aber nicht um dinge zu probieren
die ich nicht ab kann nein wir haben
heute dinge eingekauft die max nicht ab
kann und wir werden die testen und
gucken warum max die eigentlich nicht
mag will aber gar nicht lange rum leute
wir fangen direkt an mit der ersten
sache die max immer gehasst hat das war
kurz flexen diallos da magst du hast
hier unten gefühl mit den ganzen sachen
die du raus gesucht hast die du immer
gehasst hast sie doch erstmal die erste
sache die uns zeigen möchte dass über
die wir reden sein
wir haben hier preis fruchtiger knuspert
puffer ist nicht mal ist es hat immer
unsere mutter von der arbeit mitgebracht
vielleicht werden wir jetzt auch in
counter ein wie lange die anleger
gebracht
unsere mutter von der arbeit mitgebracht
okay ganz befreit
warum ist puffreis nicht macht das ist
etwas daran mussten keine ahnung so
deswegen ist wenn du so mal eine
süßigkeit essen dürfte es als kind also
elmar brok auch irgendwas was süßes oder
irgend sowas dann sei das faule ja keine
ahnung wie ist das so unzufrieden
stellen wenn das ist ja so zu 80 prozent
luft und dann ein und ist weder süß
macht irgendwas keine anpassungsprobleme
okay dann sieht aber so einig ganz geil
aus doch von haus oder sogar nicht
probiert und es hat so bisschen
esspapier jahren hat ein recht habt ihr
pappe viele leute ich probiere noch mal
so gut dass so eine ganze antwort also
ich probier's mal ganz kurz wir diese
geschmack bringt
[Musik]
es ist also noch abgeschlossen deshalb
für mich nichts halbes und nichts ganzes
als ich morgens nach dem tor nicht so
auch nicht sebastian mag es auch nicht
gesehen auch nicht bevor ich mich
täglich oder sowas aber es ist einfach
scheiße nur schlucken nicht besucht
heute nicht so lecker als nächstes die
kurze weg story dazu mag hat seine ganze
kindheit zeige einfach kein obst
gegessen und sie muss auch sagen das
ekelhafteste mit abstand ist eine reife
banane zuwider ja das finde ich auch
nicht dass das so ein gegenbesuch für
mich nie so matschig sind es nicht gar
müsst euch vorstellen man will irgendwas
essen und dann hast du dieses klebrige
haufen scheiße das ist gerade eine
perfekte ball jedoch aus diesen
überhaupt sich zu weit
die punkte die ich nicht so gut findet
eine handlung mach dir zur messe
aufkommen dass doch lecker mag es ist
einfach eine schöne ich muss ja als
dicke bananen er muss jetzt halt so
schnell essen mehr weil sonst kommt
dieses braune und da kann ich nicht mehr
ist das eben klar ich finde so lustig
gerade weil das original so die
schmutzler vermag es diesen ganzen tag
die ganze kinder lang an obst gegessen
all das ist ja immer so klebrig das ist
so die mit ist die feste banane die man
über essen kann noch ein grad fest seine
schneidezähne dabei kann man nicht sagen
leute manchmal aber keine bananen also
ich weiß ja man muss sagen wirklich
essen wirklich relativ normale sachen
die maxime eine festlichkeit die mir nie
wirklich glatt skater die gast bei
unserer oma immer also ja warum ich das
nicht mag das ist scheiße
alles klar ich glaube dass das eine
sache die noch mehr klar geht kann in
sachen heute weil es wenigstens
industriell gefertigt das nicht so
fehlerhaft wieso obst was von der natur
kommen
ja das ist lecker kocht also du magst
allgemein schwierige sache nicht
auch nicht aber ich kriege das keine so
oder so aber anders als bei einer
handelsüblichen button nicht warum
überhaupt ein mensch auf der welt so was
teil gekauft und ist also das ist jetzt
nicht irgendwie aber warum man kann
alles erst mal keine schokolade essen
man kann so leibnitz kekse essen warum
macht man sowas geisteskranken schweine
temax drei dinge erstens schon gezeigt
was hast du als nächstes da ich muss
sagen ich sie wirklich das könnte eine
normale einkaufs kauf von irgendwo die
nächste süßigkeit beziehungsweise nicht
die süßigkeit bittrich kite
bitterschokolade das video heißt ja
dinge die man als kind nicht macht eine
die immer immer gehasst hat die man als
kind immer gehasst hat oder also immer
das ding ist das video heißt ja dinge
die man als kind immer gehasst habe ich
als kind immer team war so und jetzt bin
auf jeden fall leute ich probiere ich
probiere sind noch schokolade vielleicht
schmeckt mir mittlerweile und könnte mir
sogar vorstellen weil ich meine
mittlerweile mag ich auch kaffee gin
tonic oder so lauter sachen die
eigentlich so ein bisschen so einen
bitteren geschmack haben
guck mal dies schon so extra klein
wahrscheinlich weil die zu bitter ist
dass man die ersten also jahre ist
ritter sport expertin das ist unüblich
oder das eigentlich ein stück hier
möchte kann ich hier gekürzt zeigen und
eine normale zu demonstrationen ja auch
mal essen so ok größenvergleich okay
[Musik]
bibel der leiter der stadt sächliche lag
das kann man kann man gut essen bisschen
verkehrte jetzt edelschokolade wieder
ich glaube da ist ganz klar dass man das
nicht sowieso voll mit ja stimmt weil
das bisschen intensiver ja bestimmt
gemusterten um so den geschmack zu die
bälle auf den ball sonst kriegst du
keine süße lange haare
eigentlich hab mal stand ich rate mal
warum woran es liegt dass du wieder
schokolade nicht mag es unser vater
hatte früher immer bitter schokolade im
schrank und man macht zu den kühlschrank
auf denkt sich bei irgendwas süßes essen
und dann ist nur diese dreckige
bitterschokolade da so leute als
nächstes haben wir köstlich schmeckt
liche radieschen das sieht schon ein
bisschen so wird aus ne lass uns mal
drüber nachdenken so wie dieses mal
wieder aus den filmen nicht sicher ob
man die noch warten muss
auf keinen fall bleibt jetzt schon
einmal oder wie kann man die kann man so
ist
in einem sanften fuhr ich weiß nicht was
das ist komisch dass noch so scharf ist
dann am ende schmeckt die sowieso seien
verkürzt oder nicht so einfach zumal
sich modisch ein bisschen monaten sagt
davor zum andenken an anfangen dann hat
man doch alles genießen ich muss sagen
den geschmack als kurz zu beschreiben
das gar nicht so abwegig ist wirklich so
ein bisschen ist es so passt du noch was
für uns max schnappt man die nächste
köstlichkeit
so ein käse der so weich ist wer ganz
weiterkommen geöffnet
das ist torten britischer mal nicht das
ist schon mal sehr köstlich dass er
nicht vorsätzlich wahrscheinlich essen
können ja was ist das für ein denkmal an
[Gelächter]
die nation
der vix das friedensau gewitzt etwas
hier auf der straße gericht papier dein
ernst geschmack bereits fällig war
geschmack ist das auf jeden fall einen
ordner und der fall klar weil der
vollmond ist richtig denn normalerweise
eher weniger einmal was lustig weiter
möglich ja leute ich glaube max hat nach
der aktion jetzt kein bock mehr weiter
das video aufzunehmen kann nicht
verstehen mit einem halben kilo käse im
nacken würde ich es vielleicht auch
nicht machen ganz kurz allgemeinen auch
das könnt ihr auch allen in den
kommentaren schicken also diese stelle
im video die sie zu beschweren ja okay
gut wir gehen jetzt hier bisschen
leichtfertig mit lebensmitteln um
okay das ist nicht ganz toll aber das
einfach der sinn von dem was man es
probiert ein bisschen spaß damit macht
aber das meines lebens mit an sich
verschwendet das glaube ich auch klar
und deutlich wir denken sagt die
absoluten internetexperten und kennt
jeden internet sounds gibt könnt ihr
hier drüben was das geht folge abchecken
da haben wir nämlich genau das gemacht
wir im internet zu erraten sie gerne ab
und tschüss